mariée au premier regard est ce que
c'est vrai tout ça est ce que ces trucs
qui est ce que maintenant
maintenant que c'est fini il faut nous
dire la vérité on a besoin de savoir
pour vous est ce que cette munition est
une mascarade
franchement pour moi oui pourquoi
maintenant vus le résultat et vu comment
ça s'est passé en fait faut bien
comprendre que moi la malade j'avais
j'avais posé ma candidature seuls 20 des
parts donc on n'a pas postulé ensemble
avec vous et quand ils m'ont rappelé
m'ont dit de parler de ma famille tout
ça et à ce moment là j'avais dit que
j'avais un frère jumeau et ax on dirait
et là ils se sont dits pour la bière
duction il faudrait qu'il le fasse aussi
avec toi ça serait top et tous n'ont
après je regarde le faire qu'après je
l'embarqué avec moi bien sûr il avait
envie de le faire c'est un rêve de josé
lima pérou paris il est temps de l'heure
d'été célibataire et du coup bah on l'a
fait ensemble mais j'ai l'impression
qu'en fait du coup c'était vraiment à
tout prix nous avoir dans le programme
et j'entendais trop souvent pendant les
castings les jumeaux vous adore on vous
veut absolument
on espère qu on va vous trouver une
compatibilité et je pense qu'à un moment
donné bas les compatibilités elle
s'était peut-être parce qu'elle était je
vous sont déçus de pas parce que je vous
dise en titre et sincère dans votre
démarche
moi je suis vraiment déçu je suis
vraiment déçu presque en fait marianne
c'est à l'escalet mais quand quand j'ai
vu qu'après le voyage de noces en très
peu de temps il y avait rien qui
concordait avec ma vision des choses et
même les comportements les attitudes
qu'on avait qui étaient totalement
différentes
ben c'est là que je me suis dit en fait
je me suis même senti un peu trahi par
par là même un problème avec rachid
arhab
voilà c'est sûr que bah c'est une
déception c'est une déception